believe it or not we've just finished
our first tour of the critical rendering
path let's do a quick review hold on
what about JavaScript ah okay fair
enough
so JavaScript can manipulate both the
DOM and the CSS object model but
otherwise the render process is the same
mm-hmm I see so what kind of performance
optimization should I keep in mind when
I'm using JavaScript that's a great
question and we'll get into a lot of
details on how to optimize javascript in
one of the future lessons but before we
get to that let's do a quick review try
summarizing what we learned so far about
the first path through the critical
rendering path you don't need to write
an essay just list the steps in order
that they happen and post your answers
to the forum under the post called steps
to render a page or if you don't have
access to the forms right now find a
friend and explain the critical
rendering path to them